[Music]
Disney just dropped the first teaser for
their new Lion King movie which comes
out in 2019 it's our first real peek at
the movie and what it will look like
it's got a stacked cast from Beyonce to
donald glover and it practically gives
us a shot-for-shot remake of the
original 1994 animated films opening
scene so we're here to take a super
nitpicky look at the similarities and
differences between the old and new
versions based on what we've got like
this scene they're totally different but
we're on that in a second first up both
versions seem to start with the Rising
Sun now I'm the 2019 version the Sun is
farther away not as centered there are
more trees and the colors are less
vibrant this might seem like nothing but
it actually tells us an awful lot
director Jon Favreau is going for
realism here while also trying to stay
incredibly true to the original version
and that might be a tough tightrope to
walk next we see the shot of an Oryx
that's what we decided this animal was
in Oryx now the shots look similar
although you can see that they're not a
perfect match but at least they're
looking the same direction and that's
something Oh time out let me get this
straight this next shot is even more
spot-on
it's the wide shot of these elephants
making their way to the ceremony
now the fogginess is less pronounced
here but it's still very obviously more
of a true and direct recreation from the
1994 animated film even the tops of the
mountains and the backgrounds are
similarly shaped and they both have a
trail of birds coming from the left side
of the screen
nice shot Barbara now this next shot is
iconic it's impossible to forget because
it's so gorgeous
now the 2019 version was obviously
inspired by it but it's not a direct
recreation and I'll tell you why it's
all about camera movement in the new
version we have a camera moving forward
and up revealing small patchy islands in
the water the horizon and more birds
the animated shot starts with a true
aerial shot and the only camera movement
we see is a slow pan from above
then more birds appear because more
birds simply appear before the camera
lives no different they are both
wonderful shots yeah but it's not easy
now here's our first major departure we
have this shot of zebras going wild
jumping up on two legs
we don't really see this in the original
until much later it's not until baby
Simba is presented that we see something
comparable and it's still not quite the
same alright 5-row be careful because
you're messing with our childhoods don't
do that again next up is the slow and
gorgeous zoom to reveal Pride Rock in
the new version in the original the shot
is much longer and the zoom is much much
faster in 1994 the shot tracked Zazu all
the way up to Pride Rock and we see a
prideful Mufasa standing atop it in the
2019 version we only see a little bitty
Mufasa
but perhaps Disney is only giving us a
snippet in the teaser and the shot
actually continues on in the movie
everybody's ok with this did I miss
something now it's time to meet Rafiki
his climb up the rocks seems about right
but in the original Rafiki is first
revealed walking through a crowd of
animals again who can say how it will
happen in the 2019 version Rafiki also
just looks nicer in the 1994 version you
wrote some fossa in with a friendly hug
and I'm just seeing less personality
this time around peculiar don't you
think alright here we go this is the
biggest difference we all know that read
swipe that essentially annoyed Simba as
a successor to his Father's throne well
in the original Rafiki cracks open some
type of fruit the jury is still out on
exactly what type of food it was someone
line are saying it's a passion fruit
others are saying that it's a
pomegranate I don't really know what it
is I just know that it's juicy and I
would eat it what I wouldn't eat are
those dry red sticks that Rafiki uses in
the newest version they look like
they're doused and some of that Color
Run dust I don't even know where I
freakin can find that in the jungle
anyway the way the breaking shots are
filmed is the exact same but we've got
to totally different objects and I don't
know how I feel about that is Simba
really anointed as his father successor
his forehead isn't all wet and sloppy
majesty stop it the swipe it stuff looks
right until you realize our power fee
key is using two different hands he's
using the right hand in the new version
and the left hand in the original also
only in the original does Rafiki throw
dust in little Simba's face causing him
to sneeze it's kind of rude
so maybe the new Rafiki is the nice one
after all
Rafiki lifting little Simba up is just
about an exact match but they really
play up the drama in the 1994 version
with this three shot see that my heart
is swelling with pride what I like about
the new one is that symbol looks really
scared
not only to be dangling off the edge of
a rock but he also seems to really
understand the weight of the situation
Disney recreates this roundabout scene
and they're pretty similar but this time
around
unlike the bird scene the camerawork is
actually more sophisticated in the
original animated version the bowing is
a bit more organized in the original
while in the new one the order is a
little out of whack
we've got giraffes bowing before zebras
whereas in the original we have zebras
before the giraffes but I'll allow it's
okay the zoom outs are pretty similar
but like what the zoom ends we get a
closer look of Pride Rock then in both
versions we cut to the title card I
really like the lettering in the new
version it's rugged and golden while in
the older version it's just a sort of 2d
red as you can see in both 2 L and the G
at the ends are both bigger we've got
that line in the middle there and the
fonts are the same all right just a
couple more scenes thrown in there to
dissect in the new version there's a
scene where Simba puts his paw in a
bigger paw print in the original this
moment comes when Simba and Mufasa are
having a serious conversation about
bravery and the new version it seems
like the paw print is a little bit
smaller last there's a quick shot of
what I assume is the Stampede scene
there pretty darn similar there's a bit
more green grass and the terrain is a
tad more dramatic in
original okay what's really last is what
we hear during the teaser actor James
Earl Jones reprising his role as Mufasa
says everything the light touches is our
kingdom
yada yada yeah I mean it's the same
actor saying it so it's no surprise that
it's spot-on but listen to both lines in
both versions everything the light
touches is our kingdom everything the
light touches is our kingdom they're
practically the same line reading but
that's where the differences come in
Simba says after that first line we
don't hear that in the teaser instead we
hear the word but but Aki's time is
ruler rises and falls like the Sun
there's no but in the original a king's
time as ruler rises and falls like the
Sun then in the original he goes on to
say one day Simba the Sun will set on my
time here and will rise with you as the
new king in the new teaser Jones doesn't
say the word Simba perhaps these words
were added or taken away just for the
teaser we won't know for sure until the
movie comes out in 2019 all right there
you have it what did I miss
was I wrong about anything tell us in
the comments
[Music]